hey everyone today i'm going to be
looking at a a new browser called the sr
aware iron browser as recommended to me
by a user
i will link you up in the description to
this exact website where you can find
download link to download the iron
browser
so i'm looking on it right now
and it says this is the installer for xp
and vista i'm going to download that
as opposed to the portable version and
hit open
and it's an 8.5 meg download so i'll
wait for this to finish
and i'll close safari in the background
and just wait for this to finish by
itself
this is my first attempt at installing
and using this browser so i'll do a
little review session on this in hd
so
downloading and it should come up with a
run dialog
here it is
hit run
and now i'll exit out of this
this is safari
uic came up although that was invisible
to cam studio uh you can select your
language i'll just show you guys that
these are the languages it is available
in i'm going to choose english
next
this is going to install it on my
computer so i'm going to agree to that
accept the agreement
next
program files that's exactly where it
will install it i'm going to hit next
again
and last but not least it'll add a
shortcut to the start menu folder so
i'll hit next
um i will leave a desktop icon but
uncheck the quick launch icon just
because i'm happy with what i have in my
quick launch right now
next
and this is what it's going to install
i'm good with that
so here we can see it's extracting files
this is the typical installation process
and it is done so i'm going to hit
finish
and it launches the browser instantly
and now i'm going to just
mess around with it
so first of all it's looking a lot like
google chrome right now
there's a little
little mess up with the arrow up there
but um it looks a lot like google chrome
and
my first impressions are it looks nice
it has that super bar as opposed to a
start uh url bar and a search bar so if
i want to search friend
it will automatically google friend
let's see i'm going to try an acid 3
test
i remember
doing a video and showing you guys that
uh the safari 4 webkit browser that i
showed you does pass with 100 out of 100
on the acid 3 test
and there we go it does have 100 out of
100 but it does say link test failed and
it's supposed to look like
this
so
interesting little glitch link test
uh youtube.com it is
pretty speedy although there is like a
built-in delay
again when i press it and when i
actually when i press enter in the url
bar and when it actually begins to
buffer there's a small difference
so
wikipedia.com enter three and then it
starts downloading
so um it is a pretty speedy browser
actually i do like it it um
i have to look around see what kind of
add-ons i can actually get for it oh
there we go we've made now aero was
working for a minute but then
there we go arrow actually does work
if i shrink this little
it's transparent just like google chrome
it's really reminding me of google
chrome
so um i'm guessing it's just a spin off
of the webkit in google chrome uh let's
see if it
if it can remember passwords yup it says
you want iron to save your password and
i will say yes
so i guess there's a little theme there
iron and chrome uh they go hand in hand
and
yeah it does seem to work already has
google gears installed so
yeah those are a few first impressions
of google um of iron
and there's the logo and you can
obviously unlock your
object or your rocket dock and just drag
it right in
so
that's something cool i learned today so
um
yeah if you like this
browser uh just click the link in the
description
and you can obviously
um
you can obviously download this this
browser and test it out for yourself see
how you like it over google chrome or if
you like it at all
let's see
signs oops
and here we sign into youtube and i'm
going to see if i can find you the
person who actually suggested it
um it was a comment on one of my videos
by um butter chicken
yeah so they they said they suggested
that i actually try
um this web browser
so they say they're you know it's it's
it buffers the page quite well it has
the same layout as if i were to open it
in firefox or safari
and he says safari is not the fastest
try sr wear iron it is made from the
source from google chrome which i can
tell quite easily by this layout and
everything
and it is faster than safari with the
webkit which i have yet to see it also
gets a 100 out of 100 on the acid 3 test
and in my opinion it looks better too
and i have to agree i check it out and
i'm doing a video review right now
and i'm liking it i i tried google
chrome before and it was pretty pretty
good speed i mean google chrome
obviously one of the faster web browsers
out there
and i'll i'll pull up now see how much
resources it is using
so if we go to processes we can see
firefox preloader in the background is
using about 102 megabytes and i'm going
to look all the way down to iron and
it's using only 15 megs so i'm actually
very impressed by
its resource management so that's very
very good feature
what else can i say it's not using any
cpu if i were to open
youtube.com
we see it spike a little at ten
three two
and zero and it's using sixteen makes
now so it's very very good if i were to
stream the video over here
the most i can probably get up to get it
up to 20 megabytes but that's very very
good resource management from the
browser
uh far to compare it um as
the you as the user i showed you did to
uh google
i'm sorry to safari and i opened task
manager
and say i were to go to youtube.com
we already see safari climbing to the
top at 40 megabytes
so i suppose if you don't have a lot of
ram i have four gigs of ram if you do
not have a lot of ram then it'll be a
good idea to use a less resource
intensive browser such as iron
so um i guess i would recommend this as
people just trying out new browsers i
i've already tried out opera 10 alpha
the chameleon safari webkit browser the
safari browser and now sr aware iron
browser
which works in conjunction with google
chrome so if you guys like this video uh
then go ahead and subscribe and i do a
lot of videos and you can you can send
me a personal message with a request so
should you want to
get a video done just like that
so um thanks for watching and subscribe
peace